é o meu nome é john companheiro é
italiano e à profissão do mundo
sou professor hoje gostava de vos falar
sobre este esta ideia que é pensarmos na
escola de uma forma de criar novas criar
diferentes que pensarmos na escola
dentro fora e para além da caixa
rapidamente escrevendo um pouco do meu
percurso eu mexia tempo demais em
moçambique é injustamente velho que
vamos fazer é e vinha realmente pequeno
para portugal exigir i sintra receber
perto também em almada é e aqui fiz as
minhas cores ação fiz a licenciatura fiz
meu mestrado e doutoramento
fui durante muito tempo o professor
dirigência edições de formação de
professores e trabalhei muito na questão
da integração das tecnologias em
sistemas educativos
talvez por isso em 2015 capurro
reconheceu como a ponteira michelle
pfeiffer e talvez também por isso tenha
sido convidado para no ano eu sou em
2016 iniciar um projeto em moçambique um
projeto que se chama escola box em 2016
a oportunidade de regressar à terra na
xii e desenvolver aqui um projeto de
integração das tecnologias neste
território graças muito o projeto em
moçambique este ano fui é nomeado para o
globo 20 praias que é um prémio que tem
a virtude de conhecer os professores
pelo trabalho que vem fazendo ao longo
do mundo quando foi nomeado é pouco
tempo antes tinha ficado a saber que
minha mulher estava grávida e fica aí
naquela angústia terrível de saber que é
exata em que devia partir para o dubai
onde foi é festa digamos assim
a cerimônia de entrega dos prêmios
conhecia com a data prevista para o
nascimento do meu filho no dia 15 de
março
e eu fiquei naturalmente ansioso por um
lado estava
nomeado para uma coisa que é grandiosa e
deixava naturalmente muito feliz ser
conhecido por outro lado vinha caminho a
coisa que mais importa na vida de
qualquer pessoa que é um novo conceito
mulher muito angustiada ou não vou e
elvis vai que eu aguento facto parece
que tudo correu bem
entre o dia 15 e o dia 27 fora do país
quando cheguei a portugal no dia 20
a amora tarde liguei pra minha mulher
ela já não atendia naturalmente fica é
precisamente esse prazo já venceu o
trabalho não estava em trabalho de parto
nas meninas
fui a correr pra meter mirado e horas
depois nasceu meu filho nascendo no dia
20 de março que é um dia simbólico
porque o dia internacional da feliz
idade e isso naturalmente deixou muito
ruins mas eu quero falar mas também
muito dessa coisa da felicidade e até
que ponto é que a escola deve servir
para que nós sejamos todos com isso três
questões iniciais o que é uma escola a
escola e como é curamos a escola desde
logo quando pensamos no que é escola
pensamos em alunos professores recreios
bibliotecas ginásios pensamos em
currículo avaliações pensamos em
aprendizagem provavelmente cada um de
nós tem sobre a escola idéias muito
diferentes mas muitas destas idéias
estão aqui presentes e aquilo que eu
queria perguntar se calhar como pergunta
retórica é se estas idéias se estas
coisas cá vem eventualmente numa caixa
se que o que é uma escola pode inscrever
numa caixa
atualmente os alunos e os professores
não ficariam muito apertados mas muito
daquilo que nós dizemos que é uma escola
pode efetivamente cadeira dentro de uma
caixa e é isso que tenho feito em
moçambique com um projecto que se chama
desculpa na box
o projeto é uma evolução de uma
iniciativa da unesco a unesco criou esta
iniciativa chama-se colina boxe em
países normalmente país com muitas
dificuldades semelhantes por todo o
mundo
é nós partimos do princípio que podemos
levar dentro de uma caixa é que o que é
essencial é que o que é necessário para
construir uma escola a escola tem
trabalhado ea escola primária completa
de guarapuava e uma escola tem cerca de
5 mil alunos 5 mil alunos da 1ª à 6ª
classe como fizemos ambique e cinco mil
alunos que têm aulas em condições
dificílimas desde logo porque os alunos
sentam no chão não tem cadeiras não tem
mesas as salas ontem aulas não têm
portas não tem janelas e tantas
dificuldades destes alguns destes
professores para aprenderem como
conseguem imaginar são muitíssimas mas a
creche ainda que a escola não tem salas
para mais do que 20% dos alunos cerca de
4 mil alunos desta escola tem aula a
sombra é aulas à sombra de armas é que o
acharam as salas sombra e como consegue
imaginar os desafios são muitíssimos
turmas gigantescas com 60 80 sem alguns
a ter aulas à sombra de árvores em
espaços que normalmente não são
suficientemente preservados para
desenvolver dinâmicas de aprendizagem
espaços que são atravessados por pessoas
que percorrem o rei da escola para ir em
outra os seus trabalhos ou para suas
casas portanto a escola é um espaço
fundamental limitado faça aquilo que nós
consideramos que são as condições para
aprender neste contexto e o que o
projeto exclui na box está neste momento
a fazer ainda sabe que nós vamos um
conjunto de recursos dentro daquelas
caixas por uma estreia pouco desde logo
vamos painéis solares porque trabalhamos
em territórios onde não as querem é
virar depois vans alguma tecnologia os
ipads e vamos projetores e esta é a
idéia do quarto e tecnologia 3d contest
idéia de percebermos que hoje é maior
parte dos recursos que eu preciso para a
aprendizagem estão disponíveis online
hoje todos aprendemos de forma muito
diferente daquela que aprendíamos há
muitos anos
hoje aprendemos
visando muitos recursos que estão
disponíveis online e nossa idéia é
ajudar a que estas crianças saiam de
contrastes enormes privações para que
tenham à sua disposição é que os que são
os recursos de aprendizagem conhecimento
que hoje todos nós temos e portanto
projeto tem esta virtude e estas
características
mas pensemos um pouco na segunda questão
que falava pouco pra que serve uma
escola desde logo percebemos desde a
antiguidade grega que a escola serve
para formar cidadãos e isto na
antiguidade quando a escola foi pensada
enquanto estrutura enquanto o sistema em
um grande objectivo da escola era formar
cidadãos durante a revolução industrial
ea seguir à revolução industrial criamos
um conceito de escola que era um
conceito em que ela deveria preparar as
pessoas para a atividade produtiva para
produzirem coisas e escola passou a ser
muito encarada como uma espécie de linha
de montagem pela qual os alunos iam
passando e emoção esse momento de
passagem
cada professor e adicionando qualquer
coisa e fazendo qualquer coisa
provavelmente nos tempos em que estamos
a viver e para o futuro é a idéia que a
escola deve ser um espaço produza
pessoas que saibam criar coisas porque
essa é melhor é é o melhor contributo
que nós podemos dar aos nossos alunos e
transformá-los não apenas em cidadãos
que de facto muito importante não apenas
um produtor de coisas e pessoas aptas
para ingressarem no mercado de trabalho
e terem sucesso nas constantes mas
transformá los em criadores em
construtores no seu futuro em
construtores da história das respostas
para o futuro da sociedade
a escola é e um conjunto de coisas que
estão no passado no presente e no futuro
e é um conjunto de coisas que estão no
passado porque ela é o produto de uma
experiência humana é o produto de uma
cultura fomos acumulando e que
naturalmente queremos produzir porque
por exemplo a escrita nos trouxe foi a
capacidade de fixar um saber
e temos de ensinar transmitir isso mas
ela é também presente porque ela tem que
responder a desafios desafios novos e os
desafios do presente e ela será futuro
porque quando pensamos numa criança e
algumas estavam presentes na platéia
numa criança que entrou hoje no ensino é
básico
no primeiro ano do ensino básico ela vai
estar 60 anos é terminar 60 sessenta e
mais anos até terminar a sua vida
produtiva até terminar a sua vida entre
aspas ativa e nós não conseguimos
imaginar como vai ser o mundo aqui há
seis anos quanto mais aqui 60 anos e por
isso a escola tem que preparar essas
crianças para que elas dêem respostas
aos desafios do futuro
voltemos à questão das caixas estava a
descolar de algumas caixas com as quais
não devemos comparar a escola
esta primeira caixa uma caixa negra as
escolas em relação às quais não sabemos
nada
tal como nas caixas negras dos aviões
não sabemos nada a não ser quando há
problemas também sou assim temos as
caixas negras do avião quando há
problemas normalmente quando o avião
caiu depois as escolas que têm perdido
esta dimensão de caixa de música não é
que apesar de produzirem uma melodia
mais ou menos a entender a história é
uma mundia mecânica perspectiva e nós
não queremos que as escolas sejam também
é isto
depois as escolas que são caixas
plásticas com nós guardamos usam menos e
que não queremos que as coisas se
mistura o conhecimento e sabemos que a
cada vez mais complexa construção do
saber e do conhecimento a cada vez mais
complexa e por isso o conhecimento não
deve estar reservado um espaço bastante
cremos talvez que escolas sejam caixas
primeiros corpos porque esta escola é
também uma resposta social
a escola deve procurar resolver algumas
das disfunções da nossa sociedade
procurando eventualmente criar condições
de equidade para todos independentemente
da condição da nossa origem que possamos
chegar aos mesmos sítios
a escola deve ser também uma
especificação fotos
precisamos acender a chama
alguns acham que eu posso para cada um
de nossos alunos possa brilhar
e já agora também a escola deve ser uma
imensa caixa de ferramentas para os tais
desafios do futuro e nós não conseguimos
antecipar mas sabemos que temos preparar
os alunos preços desafios
a escola deve educar para a cidade e
para o mundo através da sociedade e do
mundo não de forma isolada
a escola deve ficar para a vida através
de vida e não forma isolada temos de
trazer o mundo assistirá da minha vida
para dentro da escola e temos curvar à
escola para o mundo para a sociedade e
para a vida
quando pensamos o que cada um de nós
quer da vida provavelmente quando nós
quer coisas diferentes mas se formos ver
bem o que todos queremos é ser felizes
o serviço irá provavelmente para mim ou
para cada um de vocês uma coisa
diferente é ser feliz pode ser ter fama
pode ser enriquecer pode ser é de alguma
forma criar algo novo pode ser ter
programa progredir na sua carreira mas
em última instância é que o que todos
queremos é ser foi isso que a escola tem
que nos ajudar a este projeto e ser
feliz de ser qualquer coisa que deixar a
cabeça de qualquer projecto educativo eu
quero uma escola para construir pessoas
felizes porque esse é o objetivo da
minha vida ser feliz
como é que eu posso transformar a escola
para que isso aconteça de novo tem que
perceber que o mundo questionar e que a
vida não pára estão em permanente
evolução e portanto quando eu acho que
já dá até a escola uma qualquer
realidade posso ficar contente com os
resultados que atingir foi no momento em
que eu terei este projeto de construir
uma escola que dê resposta às
necessidades do mundo de assistir a
minha vida toda a escola não pode parar
transformar e essa transformação
tem que ser uma transformação se
quiserem dentro da caixa
incorporando que toda a experiência
humana e incorporando todo o caminho que
vamos fazendo como espécie que qualquer
coisa que nos leva orgulhar mas esta
transformação deve ser também para fora
da caixa porque sabemos que temos já
hoje problemas para os pais têm de
encontrar respostas novas respostas de
frente e provavelmente as questões do
passado não nos ajudam a encontrar essas
respostas e por um tempo temos que ir
pra lá em caixa percebendo que o mundo
pra esquerda que seis anos ou mundo vai
existir daqui a 60 anos é um mundo que
não conseguimos quer antecipar e por
isso aquela formação vamos dar aos
nossos alunos a educação vamos
transmitir é qualquer coisa que tem que
se preparar para o imprevisível por
aquilo que não existe ainda
esta transformação deve atender ao facto
da escola enquanto o sistema ser um
sistema frágil um sistema que é
premiável é todas as discussões da
sociedade
já agora essa transformação deve ser
feita sempre possível de baixo para cima
ou seja deve emergir do contexto e não
em portanto quaisquer museus não
importando francis de forma crítica que
vamos tentar replicar no nosso contexto
é que o que deve ser a transformação
vamos fazer uma transformação de ser
gerada dentro da escola com professores
com alunos com pais com toda a
comunidade para responder aquilo que é o
grande objetivo da escola que é
construir uma sociedade melhor
depois esta transformação deve ser feita
com cuidado
prevendo que nós estamos a lidar com
pessoas estamos a lidar com crianças
estamos a lidar com os jovens estamos a
lidar com família estamos a lidar com
comunidades e portanto toda a
transformação que o fizer deve ser feita
no chip pela criança pela família pela
primira e já agora também vemos que esta
mudança que fazemos devem incorporar
tudo aquilo que fomos fazendo para darão
sustentabilidade a esse processo de
transformação
por último queria falar vos de uma caixa
é caixa de pandora
dora era foi a primeira mulher criada a
pedido de zeus mulher que congregou
características propostas por todos os
deuses
o presente de casamento de pandora era
uma caixa uma caixa magnífica mas teve
uma condição pandora não poderia abrir
essa caixa
na mitologia grega dentro desta caixa
estavam todos os maus mundo adora porque
era mulher e enquanto mulher era um mané
tem essa dimensão que é uma dimensão que
talvez nos faça mais forte do que todas
as outras espécies
adora em uma imensa curiosidade e
pandora abriu a caixa o importante fato
todos os maus quando nós queremos
transformar a educação temos
naturalmente que abrir a caixa e
corremos o risco de fazer coisas mal
corremos o risco de cometer erros mas o
erro como todos sabemos faz parte do
processo de crescimento faz parte do
processo de aprendizagem dentro da caixa
de pandora fica uma coisa que nós temos
de preservar sempre idéia de que dentro
desta taxa ficou o única coisa a
esperança e temos três presenças de
transformação que estamos a fazer certo
para ter um sociedade melhor no futuro
muito obrigado
[Música]
[Aplausos]